what's up everyone welcome back to the
collider interview Studio at Sundance
20124 I am lucky enough to be sitting
with the team behind the American
Society of magical Negroes
congratulations on your moveie thank you
very much thank you so before we even
start our conversation I must give an
extra special shout out to filo our
sponsor at Sundance this year they are
allowing us to be here to support
independent filmmakers filmo is also a
special company because they are
breaking barriers by putting the power
to greenl films in the hands of fans and
creators if you want to learn more about
filo and their Community check out their
website film. Kobe you're getting my
first question again I told you this
before ambitious script right here what
was the first idea the core idea that
started it all but then I also want to
know if you had a break story moment
something that made you think like this
High concept will be a full feature film
yeah I mean it's uh I started this
project with just the premise of um
magical negro Society right and when I
first started working on it I thought it
was going to be a much shorter piece I
didn't think it was going to be a
feature because most high concept
comedic ideas should be about two
minutes long generously you know and uh
in terms of a a break story moment I it
came really early when I realized I was
writing about something much bigger um
that I wasn't just um critiquing this
particular toxic film Trope but I was
really writing about my own experience
growing up as a black person in America
and writing about defense mechanisms
that I had been taught to respond to to
to racism and um the film ended up being
a space for me to process that and um
hopefully help other people do the same
so I'm sure you go into filming with a a
rock solid script but I love hearing
about how films can evolve every single
step of the way so what would you say is
the biggest difference between draft one
of this screenplay and what everyone
will now see in the Finish feature oh
gosh I mean um yeah do you got a
protagonist name
changed um cut my song What was the name
that happened the name was Omar
originally that was your name yeah Omar
oh [__] um and wait was that the name it
was it wasn't the original Dr but then
what was the joke of like the switch
there there was a cut there's a cut joke
uh that was a word playay joke on the
old name and I think one of your biggest
concerns when we changed the name was
that that word play joke wasn't going to
work we found a new one we we sawed it
we found a new one but then they both we
cut we could see anyway so what was the
old joke the joke was someone didn't
understand the old joke Kobe director
let me just say this it was cut for a
reason you know tell us all right here's
a joke make us uh no no I I mean there
are a million little things a joke David
hold on no there this is a journalistic
tactic it's one of those jokes you
repeat the question until it's answered
I will never do this so I'm glad you're
doing it for me what was a joke it's not
a funny joke to recount it's in context
it was quite funny in the scene it it
doesn't work here uh boy you should do
standup
really I I think in some way the biggest
change from from the script to to the
finished film is just the all of the
texture that that the individual actors
bring to it you know and I I I try to be
very collaborative um um in part because
um it's just it's my sensibility but but
also uh because you know when you're
working with with artists of this
caliber they really do have you know
meaningful stuff to contribute and
sometimes that's literal language oh I I
you know I feel like my character might
say this instead of that but but other
times it's just it's just texture you
know where you know um you know the the
the the way the Integrity that David
brings to the society sort of tells all
the other actors oh okay this is how
we're approaching this you know uh where
the seriousness of purpose Justice
brings to it tells other actors that is
like oh this is not broad this is we're
playing it in this pocket over here and
so um that stuff really helps helps
refine it I remember specifically uh
Kobe and I had cuz I I I I wouldn't say
signed on to this but I I became a part
of this at the Sundance Labs um Kobe
invited me to Workshop the script with
him um and not as a writer but like as
an actor and I remember uh the biggest
issue for me with the character was his
relationship to Magic like this thing
this like uh you know the realization
that magic exists you know in order for
our audience to be connected to this
protagonist like he has to have some Rec
with like this Supernatural thing
actually exists before we get into like
the larger metaphor and the journey of
the character so I I know that we were
like really playing around with that how
astonished he is how taken him back how
how much like uh how much uh how in
denial he is that this is real you know
um that was important to Pepper in um
but still driving the narrative so like
people didn't like we didn't harp on
this thing as like you know cuz we don't
want to see a character like all the
whole movie just be like oh my God magic
is real you know because we're just like
get over it well it's one of those it's
one of those really great collaborations
I think between the different chairs we
sit in where as a filmmaker you know
it's so easy to be like everyone knows
it's a magical premise it's a secret
society we accept it pretty quickly we
don't need to spend a lot of time
adjusting to that reality because
everybody knows that premise walking in
but then as an actor Justice's point is
like this is insane I've been sucked
into a magic Society can we like take a
minute and respect that
that this is insane yeah that was my
that was my you know what though I never
mentioned this to you
but because Kobe was like a firsttime
director and we got to certain parts we
said oh but you know this is what I
wrote feel free to
improvise it I I did sense I never
addressed it because I just thought it
would make it more Awkward that if you
were double thinking overthinking what
you wrote commenting on it then I wanted
to reassure you it's well written I
don't I don't have to rewrite it I don't
have to improvise it really and it was
so I I really did not in those instances
take him up on it because I didn't think
it was needed that's all bring bringing
up that it's his first feature again
what is something about Kobe as an
actor's director and a leader that you
really appreciated on this set that
you're excited for more actors to get to
experience in the future oh my God so
much I I he is now the reference point
for how all directors need to be on set
for me anyways he's he set the presedent
um because I mean he is an actor he he's
come from that world well he thinks he's
an
actor um he tried to be an actor and so
he no he he just understands how to be
he just had he understands what the
actor's process is you know he
understands that while he it's his job
to worry about the image and the
technical nature of the of the film it's
our job to worry about the psychology so
he's only talking to us about character
but at the same time this man's
leadership is phenomenal because he
makes every Department feel heard and
seen while still holding on to his true
Vision which is so hard to balance yeah
but it was kind of I thought it was
obnoxious you know cuz Kobe he wanted to
let you know he knew everyone's name hey
hey Jinx smokes and bingo come on guys
let's check our sound I would tease him
though you know I would say like Oh Mr
first time director why don't you direct
me you don't know what the [__] you
doing you know stuff like that to make
it fun and abusive so it was
cool what is the key for you for
creating an environment like that on set
an environment where everybody feels
like seen and like their input is
valuable but while you never lose
control of your personal Creative Vision
for the film yeah well it's uh I I mean
the it's a film in in many anyways it's
a film
about people who aren't always seen
being seen right um it's a film about
background characters stepping forward
and having their moment in the sun black
characters might have been sidelined um
being being allowed to come forward and
have their moment and if you're telling
a story like that and it's it's
consistent with your values it's weird
if you're like shitty to a PA you know
what I'm saying like it's that doesn't
that doesn't really make sense right so
so beyond it just being you know a
reflection of my values it is quite
selfish about the word you know because
I do have a obviously a really Clear
Vision for what the film is and what the
texture of it is and what the
performances are in in many cases and
what all the shots look like in in many
cases but but the way it's it's a
process think about the way you you you
get to that you know and and to me what
I'm always trying to do is um uh make
people Freer to do great work so on
another movie where where that message
where it's not that message you're going
to be an [__] and be mean to everyone
oh yeah % 100% yeah this is just
specific to this piece you know I'm I'm
going to be a monster later you know uh
but but I've been I mean I did start my
careers as in actur and I've been on a
lot of sets and I've you you can watch
you can on certain sets you watch people
you watch people you watch people shrink
you know and you watch people get
smaller because um because of the the
leadership and because of the the
texture and and to me it's like you just
want people to get bigger and more
expansive and braver because no matter
how how clear a vision I have for it I'm
I'm one of my favorite things is when
someone beats my idea when like I I'm
like I have a way I think this
particular scene should go but then just
says well let's let's what if we try it
this way and the real tragedy is when
the Justice of the world stop saying
well what if we try it this way cuz you
just might miss the best version of the
scene you know also wait I just want to
sing his Praises a little bit more he
see I I'm sorry go ahead he's going to
do it one more time no I'm not what was
going I'm sorry that's my bad go ahead
go ahead what Kobe does so well we spend
some time together does so well is that
he um he he organizes what's going to
happen during the shoot he's so well
organized uh and he allows T like uh he
he um a lots time for experimentation so
every single Department um like when
they have an idea and and he he sees a
route of it he sees like value in it
he's going to try it he's going to
experiment with it and all the time it
like sometimes it doesn't work you good
I just like slight case of Co but go
ahead sometimes it doesn't work you know
but sometimes it's like it's like what
he says it beats his idea it beats his
original idea but I think like when you
have someone who is is so open to trying
things and experimenting like you don't
feel as bad if it if it doesn't work out
in the end if it gets cut or or whatever
because you feel respected because you
feel like you were hired for a reason
because you're trusted as an artist you
know um and that's why it was one of the
most well-oiled films I've ever been on
like oiled like like well oiled machines
I just I'm thinking I wasn't really in
I'm sorry and I have threats
stop I don't even know what I was saying
oh it worked anyway it was a well oiled
machine it was a well oil machine it was
a well oil machine but why is it so
sexual like you know it was oil and
massage lubricated and when he was
aroused I mean intellectually uh it
helped us achieve our climactic acting
moments if you know what I mean yeah
okay then that's right I mean film
making is sexy I get it I get it it
ain't that sexy uh but I have been on
hostile sets have you in which it's run
more like a mutinous yes Battleship yes
where literally the crew is like they're
either going to set up the shot or beat
your ass and that's no fun that is no
fun that's when I switch into a survival
mode and just let me do my thing get get
out of here as quick as I can which most
of the days that's really what it was
like
with I called him black Stalin if that
if that informs you we've been asking a
a filo inspired question and I feel like
it does lean into a lot of what you've
been describing so like I said at the
beginning filo is a company that's all
about putting creative control in the
hands of the creator which I think is a
very important thing that this industry
needs more of whether it's on this film
or anything else you've worked on can
you give me an example of a time when
someone gave you creative control when
you didn't expect to get
it on this on this film anything or
anything I'm saying on this film like
this is this is the most creative
control I've had um I'm I'm a control
freak and being an act being an actor is
not really um the job for that because
you don't at the end of the day um at
least being a film actor you don't get
to control your performance it's all in
the edit it's all in the hands of the
director um and I remember in earlyer in
my career I used to do um every take the
same way so I had some like like grasp
of like this is mine like it's my
performance you know and I and I learned
that that ultimately makes the
performance stale you know and you have
to trust your um your captain but I I
had never experienced so like
collaboration like this you know and at
times I had to like check myself because
I'm like but Kobe this is your movie and
this is your you know because he would
he would often want to hear my ideas you
know about like casting and about lines
and about um story beats and you know he
would give me so much freedom to
improvise things and and uh like beef up
moments like the Lego scene and um I I
just I felt so um
uh equal to him um and that's a
dangerous feeling uh because now I
expect so much when I go on film sets I
mean to be fair you should expect that
of your collaborators that's true it's
not as common as you think it's it's not
common but it should be it is it is
shocking I guess I mean the most
autonomy I would probably say In Living
Color um because Keenan was from the
beginning he said you can sit in your
dressing room and wait for these writers
to come up with sketches but if you're
not being served write your own stuff
pitch your own stuff uh come to me with
these ideas that's how you will get the
most from this show so that's probably
the last time where I really uh felt
that much autonomy and I personally as
an actor I don't like coming in because
I've been in that situation where it's
like you know the protagonist gets on an
elevator enter David and he's gonna be
funny I'm like dude give me some lies
you know what you do man just come up
with some stuff and you're like I want
to structure yeah
yeah want to take us on with this one uh
yeah for me I I think it's it's this
piece too I you know it's it's a piece
that is incredibly specific to
my experience right and uh that
experience is in incredibly black and it
is very particularly black it's not
necessarily you know the way I've
processed racism and the way I've
responded to it and my particular
defense mechanisms in the face of it are
not every other black person's you know
and and because of that I think it's a
distinct black film and um I was have at
various points in my career as you can
imagine um had uh encountered racism in
Hollywood it's come up um but but you
know once I was with these producers
inside on scene and these this
distributor at focus it they they were
very supportive about just really
listening to me and and and when I say
this is what this film is this is what
my experience is uh uh it was uh
respected in a way that I feel very
lucky to live right now because I you
know I sometimes play a game with my
black filmmaker friends of like how long
ago would this film have not been green
lit you know is it like is it 3 years is
it 5 years is it 10 years you know what
I mean it's like 10 it's you know I
think about my my career and how I I
wouldn't have had a career like if I was
acting in like the early 2000s you know
like the roles that I played are so
specific to the time periods that they
were in you know um so yeah I think
about
time beautiful answers all around I have
to let you go so you could celebrate
movie some more so I'm going to say
thank you for your time thank you for
sharing your experience with us and huge
congratulations thanks so much thank you
to everybody out there thanks for
watching stay tuned for more from
Sundance 2024 and thank you
filo